If you ever find yourself falling into a volcano,
there are a couple of
things you should know.
First off, when you reach the bottom,
the magma's not going to swallow
you up as it does in the movies.
In fact, the odds of your body even
making it to the end of the fall are pretty low.
And considering what would happen
if you did reach the bottom,
you'd probably be better off that way.
This is WHAT IF,
and here's what would
happen if you fell into a volcano.
All it takes is one glimpse
of a volcano to tell you that it's
something you should probably avoid.
The bright magma that spews from its core
can reach temperatures
of up to 1,000°C (1,832°F),
hot enough to completely
incinerate a human body.
And things aren't much better on the outside,
as the rim of a volcano is filled with enough
toxic gases to kill anyone who gets close to it.
So with all that considered,
is it even possible to get close enough
to the mouth of a volcano to fall in?
There aren't many scenarios that could
lead to you tumbling inside a volcano,
but that doesn't mean it's impossible.
For instance, let's say you're
out with a hiking group
approaching the peak of a volcano.
As you get closer, you start
to feel really hot and woozy;
you think you must just
be getting exhausted, but no,
you're actually dying.
You see, at the rim of a volcano
temperatures will be hitting 500°C (932°F),
plus you’d be breathing in copious
amounts of sulfur, methane,
carbon monoxide and ammonia.
It would only be a matter of
time until asphyxiation sets in,
which would cause you to
lose consciousness and fall.
But you probably wouldn't have
made it close enough to the opening
to actually fall into the volcano,
so maybe this scenario doesn't work.
If we want to understand what
would happen if you fell into a volcano,
we're probably best to
avoid the rim altogether
and just drop you in from a helicopter.
Maybe you're an aerial photographer,
just about to capture the
bubbling beauty of the lava lake below
when the helicopter starts to whip.
back and forth uncontrollably.
Ash clouds that hang above volcanoes
have been known to wreak havoc
with airplane engines and
flight components in general,
and in the ensuing chaos,
you could get thrown from the chopper!
The fall itself isn't going to last long for you,
because within seconds you'll probably
have passed out from lack of oxygen,
and ignited into flames from the radiant heat.
And it doesn't get much better after that.
Magma can be thousands to millions
of times more viscous than water,
which means when your body makes
contact with it you are going to hit hard.
Like, hard enough to break most
of the bones in your body.
Ok so flaming skin, seared lungs, broken
bones and now you’re stuck on the surface
since it is generally agreed lava and
magma don’t let people sink,
at least not more than a few centimeters.
Oh, and did we mention that
you'd ignite into another
ball of flames when you hit the surface?
In the blink of an eye, it would be just
your bones and ashes on top of the lava,
and your bones won’t stick around long.
So if you fell into a volcano, it's likely that the
only way you're getting out is in an urn.
But, surprisingly enough, there
have been some survivors.
In 2007, a Maasai porter fell into
a volcano but managed to pull himself out;
despite suffering severe burns
to one arm and both of his legs.
The main reason for his being
able to make it out alive
is because the lava he fell
into was natrocarbonatite lava,
which is only half as hot as most other lavas.
In general, though, it's a good idea
to avoid volcanoes altogether.
Sure it would take a very specific set of
circumstances for anyone to fall inside one, but
but there are plenty of other threats
that could kill you before that happened.
Maybe one day we'll be able to find a
purpose for a volcano's destructive nature,
like using it for a waste incinerator,
but that's a topic for another WHAT IF.